je suis très heureux d'être devant vous
pour vous présenter ma candidature à la
présidence de public sénat et vous
exposer mon projet pour les trois
prochaines années
nous vivons un moment sans précédent de
crises sanitaires économiques sociales
culturelles de crise de l'information et
de fragilité démocratique
j'ai réfléchi et si j'ai décidé de
solliciter à nouveau votre confiance
c'est parce que je suis habité par une
conviction et elle est la raison de mon
engagement c'est que la mission de notre
chaîne parlementaire retisser le lien
entre la politique et les français
cette mission n'a jamais été aussi
crucial aussi nécessaire aussi actuel or
cette période si difficile avec notre
identité
elle est aussi riche de formidables
opportunités pour expliquer au plus
grand public
votre action celle de tous les sénateurs
avec pluralisme et impartialité en
prenant le temps de la pédagogie pour
répondre à l'aspiration de plus en plus
forte des français à la proximité et
pour nourrir avec vous le débat d'idées
constructif sur nos enjeux d'avenir du
fond et pas du clas alors cette vision
je peux en témoigner elle est partagée
par l'ensemble de l'équipe que j'ai la
chance de diriger leur implication jeu
les mesures et plus encore dans cette
année de pandémie la capacité de toutes
et tous
non seulement de s'adapter mais surtout
d'innover
alors oui nous avons des appuis solides
l'élan est là et je veux maintenant
mettre toute mon énergie pour faire plus
que jamais de public sénat
le média parlementaires de tous les
publics
public sénat tout public
ce projet cap 2024 il a trois grandes
ambitions
un élargir la visibilité de votre action
et du rôle du sénat deux approfondir le
lien que nous avons avec les territoires
3 déployés aussi une nouvelle approche
numérique multiplateforme et à la dom
hand et tout cela dans un cadre de
gestion maîtrisée que j'évoquerai
ensuite c'est donc d'abord et c'est mon
premier point une nouvelle ambition pour
le rayonnement du sénat et l'action des
sénateurs je vous propose de déployer
pleinement ce que j'appelle le multiplex
parlementaire de quoi s'agit-il de la
possibilité de diffuser plusieurs
contenus liés à l'agenda du sénat
avec un format adapté à chaque
plateforme par exemple pendant que le
débat sur l'opération barkan et
retransmis sur la tnt bien un de nos
journalistes s'adresse sur nos abonnés
facebook comment une audition par
exemple sur les questions de laïcité et
dialogue avec les internautes
nous toucherons ainsi de plus en plus
des publics multiples avec des sujets et
des formats spécifiques c'est public
sénat est à vous et puis je veux ajouter
plus d'interaction avec les citoyens à
la rentrée sur l'écran télé nous
afficherons des qr codes à scanner qui
renverront à des contenus
complémentaires sur notre site et à la
possibilité de poser des questions ou de
commenter le mercredi c'est la journée
événement des questions au gouvernement
eh bien j'ai introduit ray des questions
citoyennes recueillies en vidéo sur les
réseaux sociaux qui vous seront
adressées lors du débrief après la
séance
un autre aspect de votre rayonnement
au-delà de votre activité ici au palais
du luxembourg
c'est votre lien avec vos territoires et
pour mieux le faire vivre
je propose à la rentrée un nouveau grand
rendez vous installé dans notre
carrefour de 22 heures l'émission
s'appellera réinventons la france elle
sera réalisée en région dans un lieu
emblématique avec en fil rouge l'un
d'entre vous une sénatrice un sénateur
entouré d'acteurs locaux de merde
entrepreneurs de citoyens vous
dialoguerait et réagir et avec eux à des
reportages de la rédaction
illustrant dans tous les domaines les
innovations qui vont redynamiser notre
pays
construire le monde d'après par
l'initiative de terrain et qui seront
des sources d'inspiration je veux faire
de public sénat
le média de la relance par les
territoires
et cela m'amène à mon autre ambition
c'est mon deuxième point faire vivre
cette énergie des territoires notre
force
votre force c'est cet ancrage
territorial et le refus du du
parisianisme
cet ancrage doit irriguer l'ensemble de
nos programmes et inclure tous les
territoires de métropole et des outre
mer voilà le pacte territoire que je
vous propose le sénat c'est la maison
des collectivités locales et bien public
sénat sera la maison des médias locaux
je propose une alliance stratégique
globale avec la presse quotidienne
régionale et les télévisions locales
indépendantes dont celle des outre-mer
et j'engagerai cette démarche dès ce
printemps
concrètement l'accord inclut en
particulier un club de la presse des
régions dans la perspective des
prochaines échéances électorales
notre participation et notre relais à
des événements de presse quotidienne
régionale dans les territoires notre
association aussi à des actions d'un pqr
en faveur de l'éducation aux médias je
m'engagerai avec territoire tv nouveau
réseau des télévisions locales de la pqr
pour coproduire à la rentrée sur notre
plateau leur nouveau rendez vous commun
d'actualité vitrine des chaînes qui sera
diffusée en complémentarité sur public
sénat
troisième direction public sénat tout
public c'est un média multi plateformes
et à la demande
cela repose sur la distribution et le
déploiement de nos contenus au delà de
la télévision sur tous les écrans alors
nous avons déjà le replay la télé de
rattrapage mais on doit répondre encore
davantage aux nouvelles habitudes de
consommation numérique à la fois sur le
web via les box des opérateurs les
réseaux sociaux les nouvelles
plateformes
c'est aussi un moyen de toucher un
public plus large et plus jeune
sur la plateforme twitch nous avons été
les premiers à vous faire dialoguer avec
les jeunes
et ça marche et bien ce temps d'avant
son va le garder avec d'autres formats
innovants sur d'autres réseaux sociaux
tout cela va prendre force dans une
nouvelle offre public sénat à la demande
publicsenat.fr va devenir une
plate-forme ou avec des vignes
est claire et attractive chacune et
chacun trouve gratuitement bien sûr et à
tout moment
tous les contenus qui l'intéressent où
je veux quand je veux surtout écran
voilà le nouveau public sénat
concrètement je vais mettre en ligne en
janvier 2022
un site internet entièrement rénové à
côté des articles d'actualité il sera
aux meilleurs standards du moment pour
la mise à disposition de la diversité de
nos productions des auditions
parlementaires les documentaires bien
sûr mais aussi des formats exclusif pour
le web et sur le mobile en janvier 2023
ce sera le lancement de l'appli public
sénat elle portera au plus l'eau au plus
haut ce qu'on peut appeler l'expérience
public sénat alors vous allez me
demander pourrons-nous concilier cet
élan nouveau ce projet ambitieux avec la
rigueur budgétaire
et bien la réponse est oui et je veux en
prendre l'engagement
j'en viens donc à la gestion de
l'entreprise je m'inscris pleinement
dans la perspective d'une poursuite du
gel en valeur absolue de notre dotation
et d'une stricte limitation pour
l'évolution de notre masse salariale
jusqu'en 2024
c'est par des économies de gestion et
donc en dégageant des marges
d'autofinancement que nous allons
assurer notre développement territorial
et numérique et avec aussi un nouvel
effort sur le parrainage la rigueur de
gestion elle repose également sur une
relation solide et constructive avec lcp
assemblée nationale
la limite c'est notre autonomie et notre
indépendance qu'il faut absolument
préserver à vos côtés
je ne mettrai jamais le doigt dans un
engrenage qui aboutirait à une forme de
confusion voire un esprit de fusion qui
serait contraire aux bicamérisme et
diluerait la marque forte public sénat
qui porte le sénat en elle mais dans le
même temps je souhaite une coopération
volontariste en optimisant la gestion de
notre canal commun et de notre diffusion
en renforçant aussi nos synergies
éditoriales
je propose par exemple une nouvelle
émission commune à dialogue entre
députés et sénateurs pour montrer ce
bicamérisme en action je termine avant
notre échange
nous avons affirmé ces dernières années
notre singularité
on est différent des autres puis nous
avons démontré notre modernité une
nouvelle image un nouveau ton devant
nous ce que je veux aujourd'hui pour
public c'est là c'est renforcer notre
puissance 2021 2024 si vous m'accordez
votre confiance
ce sera pour public sénat le temps du
rayonnement le socle d'audience et la
plus de 29 millions de téléspectateurs
sont venus sur notre canal en avril 2020
c'est un record la fréquentation note
site publicsenat.fr a doublé en un an et
nous allons encore progresser l'audience
est un indicateur de succès mais jamais
contrairement à d'autres médias
le critère de décision éditoriale ce qui
prime c'est notre rayonnement dans le
paysage audiovisuel numérique et
politique
voilà l'objectif alors l'état d'esprit
que je veux insuffler aux équipes c'est
que tout est possible et si je suis là
aujourd'hui devant vous c'est pour
relever le challenge de ces défis
nouveaux et essentielle en ces temps
d'incertitude entretenir avec nos
concitoyens plus encore renouer avec
notre jeunesse
une conversation républicaine je ne vois
pas de mission plus exaltante à ce
moment de notre histoire
à ce moment de mon parcours de missions
plus proche de vos valeurs et de celle
du sénat
merci monsieur kessler nous allons
maintenant passer au temps des échanges
avec la commission et nous allons donc
procéder à toute une série de questions
auxquelles vous allez répondre et je
vais me permettre de poser la première
de ses six questions
alors monsieur kessler selon vous quels
sont les principaux enjeux et défis de
public sénat dans le paysage audiovisuel
actuelle comment définiriez-vous ses
missions intrinsèque
qu'est ce qui la différencie des autres
chaînes monsieur kessler en particulier
les chaînes d'information vous avez
parlé
le cpn et des coopérations et qu'est ce
qui la différencie aussi et est ce que
vous pouvez vous préciser cet aspect des
choses
résidente cette différenciation elle est
en effet très importante aujourd'hui
elle est de plus en plus et elle passe
par plusieurs caractéristiques
la première je crois c'est le temps long
ce que nous avons dans l'univers
numérique à travers le fracas et la
succession des tweets et sur les chaînes
d'information ou un événement chasse
l'autre j'allais dire à toute vitesse
sans toujours d'ailleurs que la
hiérarchie soit compréhensible c'est une
une succession d'infos dont les
téléspectateurs en besoin à titre d'
alerte mais qui ne suffit pas a
comprendre a expliqué à donner du sens
et donc la caractéristique de public
sénat
c'est ce temps long cette prise de
distance cette capacité de de réflexion
que nous avons dans nos débats des
débats qui peuvent être contradictoires
mais qui sont constructifs ou d'ailleurs
à l'image de ce qu'est votre assemblée
on peut confronter des opinions
divergentes mais où il ya toujours du
respect et moi je crois c'est pour ça
que j'ai parlé de conversations
républicaine que cette tonalité là elle
est extrêmement marquantes
le deuxième point qui nous différencie
des chaînes d'information c'est la
capacité
je dirais d'avoir une information plus
riche et plus variée qui s'appuie
d'ailleurs sur votre activité
car bien souvent sur les chaînes
d'information vous avez pendant une
journée le même titre développé à
l'infini or chez nous où je vais vous
prendre un exemple la discussion sur la
proposition sécurité globale et bien la
plupart des chaînes d'information se
sont concentrés uniquement sur cet
article 24 et nous mêmes nous avons mis
en avant votre débat sur les polices
municipales qui est un débat qui est
extrêmement concernant pour les citoyens
et sur lequel les médias qu'ils allaient
dire cherche d'abord les faits
politiques au sens pardon et je n'ai
fait pas une critique de politique
peut-être plus politiciennes ne mettent
moins l'accent c'est ça notre devoir
c'est ça notre mission en s'appuyant
encore une fois sur l'ensemble de vos
travaux je vous en ce moment la richesse
des missions d'information qui font
suite à la situation de pandémie dans
laquelle nous sommes sur les jeunes sur
la pauvreté
eh bien je crois que nous avons une
matière
formidable à mettre en avant extrêmement
saine généraliste elle le sera chez nous
je termine sur lcp assemblée nationale
nous avons des complémentarités je les
dis il faut travailler ensemble mais ce
qui me paraît important c'est aussi
notre spécificité et c'est notamment
cette dimension territoriale qui non
seulement est là parce que nous sommes
l'émanation du sénat et c'est déjà
considérable
mais là aussi parce que cela correspond
aujourd'hui et ils le disent à toutes
les attentes des français et nos
associations nos partenariats avec les
associations d'élus
notre présence dans les grands congrès
de l'association des maires de france ou
des régions c'est une marque forte de
public sénat notre présence sur le
terrain des plusieurs départements
visités chaque semaine c'est une marque
forte qu'il va falloir continuer à
développer d'ailleurs je propose de
nouveaux axes dans ce partenariat par
exemple avec les associations d'élus
kessler la parole et à monsieur joël
guerriau merci madame la présidente
monsieur kessler dans votre propos
introductif vous avez montré votre
volonté de diversifier le public f à
l'audience de lâcher et d'augmenter la
violence de la chaîne par de nouveaux
outils
vous avez présenté votre projet
multiplex parlementaire on voit bien que
vous avez l'intention de faire évoluer
les modalités de diffusion de public
sénat sur la tnt
j'aimerais savoir quels sont les à quel
horizon où vous voulez faire d'autre
d'autres projets avec quel mode art and
alternative de diffusion souhaitez vous
privilégié dans ce cadre là vous avez
bien sûr plusieurs vecteurs que vous
avez cités vous avez cité facebook vous
exciter les réseaux sociaux que vous
avez déjà plus ou moins prêter puisque
vous parliez tout à l'heure en
introduction de l'opération barkan avec
facebook
alors quelles sont les initiatives que
vous souhaitez plus légers maintenant et
où pensez-vous que vous gagnerez encore
davantage d'audience ce qui me paraît
d'abord très important il ya un
préalable c'est que notre diffusion sur
la tnt demeure incontournable et
indispensable parce que d'abord elle
nous a fait arriver en 2005
vous allez dire dans la ligue 1 de
l'audiovisuel enfin dans le club fermé
des chaînes qui compte
et aujourd'hui on se bat pour être sur
la tnt d'ailleurs vous avez que le csa
ne va pas changer les numéros c'est
notre
ans parce que le numéro 13 il nous a
porté chance pourquoi la tnt demeure
indispensable même si elle un monsieur
le testeur nous en parlons parfois un
coût élevé c'est parce que 20% des
foyers français ne reçoivent la
télévision que par la tnt que c'est un
mode gratuit sans collecte de données et
universel qui couvre la totalité de nos
territoires et donc ici plus qu'ailleurs
je pense qu'on est attaché par rapport à
notre mission de service public à la tnt
alors après il faut en maîtriser les
coûts nous avons négocié d'ailleurs avec
nos amis d'al cpam pour faire en sorte
que le prestataire de diffusion
principal tdf n'augmentent pas trop ses
coûts mais je dirais qu'à moyen terme
d'ailleurs le csa est plutôt sur une
optique de modernisation de la tnt la
tnt c'est vraiment un enjeu de
démocratie audiovisuelle
dans le même temps bien entendu de plus
en plus de français et notamment les
jeunes qui ne regardent plus la
télévision reçoivent des signaux par
d'autres canaux ya les box des
opérateurs
il y a ce qu'on appelle le tt je veux
pas être technique mais ce sont toutes
ces plateformes qui permet de recevoir
le signal télévisé sur son ordinateur
sur son mobile et nous devons avoir
c'est un peu ce que j'expliquais une
stratégie de présence la plus large
possible à la fois sûre c'est à dire le
flux notre chaîne et sur ses émissions
cette consommation
pardon d'employés là encore un terme un
peu techniques de plus en plus
délinéarisée c'est-à-dire émissions par
émissions contenues par contenu
indépendamment de la programmation le
tue à la télévision on donne rendez vous
aux téléspectateurs mais il faut lui
offrir sur l'ensemble des plateformes
l'ensemble des outils et avec les
formats adaptés parce qu'on ne s'adresse
pas de la même façon à un public sur
facebook ou sur molotov
on peut aussi mettre des vignettes sur
nos émissions eh bien il faut offrir
toute cette gamme de possibilités pour
les contenus public sénat donc raisonner
en termes de contenu et plus seulement
c'est l'évolution d'aujourd'hui en
termes de télévision la parole est un
monsieur vincent capo-canellas
merci madame la présidente monsieur
questerre le contenu le contexte pardon
budgétaire contrat vous l'avez vous même
rappeler comment comptez vous continuer
à m mieux encore à l'antenne en valeur
tous les territoires y compris les
outre-mer en tenant bien sûr compte et
en rendant compte de l'activité des
sénatrices et des sénateurs sur le
terrain dans l'existant dans l'exercice
de leur mandat
par ailleurs comment bien d'assurer
l'égalité femmes hommes à l'antenne
alors commence peut-être pas la dernière
partie de votre question je suis
évidemment très hâte il est très attaché
la parité doit être un objectif
elle est dans le fonctionnement de
l'entreprise c'est important un comité
de direction entièrement paritaire un
indice même d'égalité femmes hommes qui
est plus favorable au vote aux femmes
dans notre entreprise c'est un élément
positif
et puis vous me parlez de la parité à
l'antenne d'abord nous avons plus de
présentatrice que deux présentateurs
mais la grosse difficulté ce sont les
plateaux avec les expertes en parité
avec les experts
reconnaissez avec moi qu'il y a encore
une majorité d'hommes parmi les
sénateurs
l'ensemble de votre collègue même si la
féminisation a beaucoup progressé
donc ça c'est un élément ne maîtrisons
pas mais nous nous entourons c'est très
difficile d'arriver à la parité je peux
vous dire que mes équipes disent même
que depuis la pandémie c'est devenu
encore plus difficile peut-être parce
qu'il ya encore des contraintes qui
pèsent plus sur les femmes que sur les
hommes mais nous travaillons par exemple
avec un think tank agir pour l'égalité
pour essayer au maximum de reconnaît me
affiche des choses je pense que ce qui
est important c'est de mesurer notre
profession d'année en année et nous
pourrons l'indiqué dans notre prochain
contrat d'objectifs et de moyens pour ce
qui concerne la contrainte budgétaire
je veux en faire une opportunité je
considère que avoir un budget gelé tel
que le nôtre nous oblige
et ça représente un effort chaque année
a beaucoup d'imagination a beaucoup
d'agilité et nous allons continuer à
développer notre présence territoriale
et numérique grâce à des économies de
gestion
nous en avons fait vous l'avez suivi
monsieur le questeur avec nous avec
l'interniste l'internalisation de
l'exploitation des personnels qui
exploitent notre régie de production
c'est une marche d'économie assez
importante moi je souhaite poursuivre
sur cette tendance en examinant
l'ensemble de nos contrats de
prestations pour voir comment on peut
pas tout internaliser mais sur certaines
prestations nous pouvons internaliser
davantage autrement dit ce qui a été
initié je souhaite le poursuivre nous
allons par exemple se négocier
prochainement notre contrat de diffusion
de notre signal une fois produit ce
qu'on appelle la régie de diffusion
il ya probablement des choses que nous
pouvons faire pour dégager des économies
donc autofinancement par des économies
et fort également sur le parrainage
si pour la quatrième question mais c'est
loïc hervé monsieur kessler trois
mandats la suite ne serait ce pas trop
long comment se remettre en cause quand
on a déjà mis en place une nouvelle
organisation et nouvelle grille par
exemple comment mieux faire connaître
l'institution sénatoriales et les
responsabilités que nous exercions
comment également développer de nouveaux
partenariats avec les réseaux sociaux
avec la pqr mais de manière plus précise
que ce que vous savez pu nous dire en
propos liminaire
comment améliorer la gestion bref
qu'elle serait quels sont vos marges de
progression ce qui m'intéresse c'est
l'avenir et donc je considère qu'il faut
toujours progresser et aller de l'avant
nous avons un socle mais j'ai essayé
d'expliquer que nous avions un projet
ambitieux pour ce temps du rayonnement
de public sénat
alors ce mandat si vous m'accordez votre
confiance je ne vois pas comme un
troisième mandat mais comme le premier
mandat de l'après crise je sais que vous
ne pourrez pas vous ne ferez pas votre
choix sur un bilan je vous propose de
faire votre choix sur un élan c'est cet
élan que je veux incarner parce que je
crois profondément à l'utilité à la
valeur de ce que nous représentons
public sénat et de la visibilité de
votre action que je veux accentuée en
suivant par exemple on a beaucoup
progressé sur la présence des auditions
grâce avoue d'ailleurs qu'il est captée
davantage
je pense qu'on peut faire encore un
petit peu plus je n'ai pas dit tout à
l'heure sur la notion de prospective
dans ce monde de demain
vous avez beaucoup avec la délégation à
la prospective avec en commun avec
l'assemblée l'opex l'office sur les
choix scientifiques et technologiques
avec la délégation aux droits des femmes
énormément de travaux qui dessine ses
perspectives je voudrais créer un
rendez-vous qui s'appellera les lundis
de la prospective où on mettra en avant
tout cette réflexion que vous avez sur
ce monde nouveau que nous allons bâtir
après cette crise du duke duke au vide
je voudrais ajouter concernant la durée
du mandat un élément c'est que le mandat
des présidents des chaînes
parlementaires et le plus court de tout
l'audiovisuel public dans les autres
sociétés de l'audiovisuel il est de 5
ans et donc au fond trois mandats si ce
devait être le cas à la présidence de
public sénat c'est moins que deux
mandats à la présidence de france
télévisions et puis dans vos
collectivités
quand un maire a bâti vous l'avez été
pour certains d'entre vous a commencé à
bâtir au bout de six ans il n'a pas fini
voilà on a commencé à tracer un chemin
il faut aller beaucoup plus loin être
encore beaucoup plus plus ambitieux
surtout dans une période où tout est où
tout et refonder et puis je crois aussi
que dans une période comme celle que
nous connaissons il faut à la fois
l'élan la créativité
j'ai essayé de vous le montrer par tous
les aspects que je souhaite développer
pour la période à venir
et puis une certaine forme de stabilité
qui nous ancre et qui ancre sur tous les
collaborateurs dans une forme de
confiance dans l'avenir voilà ce que je
veux vous proposer pour les trois
prochaines années pour public sénat
merci madame benbassa
bonjour monsieur kessler comme en public
sénat pourrait-elle former les jeunes à
la vie publique et aux valeurs
républicaines
ne pourrait-on pas organiser des débats
avec de jeunes élus locaux et des
sénatrices et sénateurs ou encore créer
une émission tournée vers les jeunes
incarné par un animateur de la jeune
génération
si oui comment imaginer auriez-vous ce
type d'émission plus généralement et
quelles seraient vos propositions pour
conquérir de nouveaux publics
merci oui madame la sénatrice il faut en
effet aller vers les jeunes en sachant
que c'est difficile parce qu il se défie
de la politique parce qu'ils ne
regardent plus la télévision
donc il faut pas chercher forcément à
faire des émissions de télévision au
sens classique du terme ils ne la
regarde plus c'est pour ça mais je n'y
reviens pas que nous sommes allés sur
twitch mais il faut poursuivre dans
cette direction
alors je propose deux choses d'abord je
pense que le dialogue entre les
politiques et notamment ceux qui sont en
contact des réalités de terrain et les
jeunes ça fonctionne donc je propose de
mettre en place une émission qui va
s'appeler dialogue jeunes citoyens on va
travailler avec des rectorats des
collèges et des lycées pour que deux
fois par an six sénateurs viennent
dialoguer autour de deux questions et
d'enjeux que nous aurons préparer avec
eux avec neuf jaunes six de 9,2 collège
et puis ensuite de lisser on fera
quelques émissions par an à titre de
test
le deuxième point c'est que je crois
pour s'adresser aux jeunes et pour les
ré ancré dans la république
plus que des propositions éditoriales et
on va faire des choses sur les réseaux
sociaux il faut leur proposer des
projets
rappelez-vous ce formidable film
d'ariane ascaride où elle arrive à
sensibiliser une classe rétive
un concours sur l'histoire de la
déportation
alors ce que nous pouvons faire et je
vais le proposer aux associations d'élus
vous me parliez de partenariat tout à
l'heure je veux bien sûr développer
encore ses partenariats
c'est un concours
auprès des jeunes vis ta ville vis ton
village vita banlieue où nous allons
leur demander de filmer leur territoire
dans un format réseau social type
youtube et nous allons préparer bien sûr
avec des associations d'élus partenaires
une sorte de cahier des charges pour
essayer de les impliquer dans un projet
et puis il y aura des prix on peut même
le doter ce cri pour véritablement
inciter et crée aussi de l'an viii et
peut-être lé envie de continuer et je
pense que c'est aussi un élément de de
lien social et de cohésion républicaine
que l'on peut créer donc d'une part des
offres éditoriales et numérique en
n'étant pas trop classique sur le plan
de la télévision et d'autre part des
projets qui vont impliquer les jeunes et
sensibiliser à ce qu'est le sénat et
public sénat comme vecteur de
d'intégration républicaine aussi oui
merci
la parole est à madame fillol votre
projet stratégique pas plus que votre
présentation liminaire ne fait de
propositions concernant la mesure de
satisfaction du public qui constitue
pourtant une préoccupation importante
pour une chaîne de service public
pourquoi cet angle mort avez vous des
propositions dans ce domaine
merci merci madame la sénatrice bien
entendu et jour je trouve que
effectivement c'est sous cet angle là
qu'il faut poser la question
plus que sur celui de la mesure
d'audience j'ai dit tout à l'heure ce
qui compte c'est notre influence notre
présence bien sûr nous avons quelques
indicateurs d'audience qui nous
permettent de mesurer la force de nos
programmes par exemple les questions
d'actualité par exemple nos
documentaires mais ce qui est très
important c'est de mesurer la
satisfaction de nos publics donc ça
n'est pas du tout un angle ce n'est pas
du tout part dans un angle mort de mon
projet parce que je me situe
pour que ce soit fiable dans une
tendance qui existe déjà depuis 2014
tous les trois ans nous effectuerons
pardon depuis 2011 tous les trois ans
depuis qu'il ya un contrat d'objectifs
et de moyens d'ailleurs à une étude
qualitative
avec la même méthodologie le même
institut pour mesurer la satisfaction de
nos publics et nous en avons fait une
raison récemment qu'ils montrent
qu'effectivement la modernisation ne
tienne là et surtout je dirais la
confiance du public dans ce moment du
dîner au début de crise de l'information
est très fort dans le contenu public
sénat quand on regarde public sénat on
croit ce qu'on est en train de voir ou
de lire sur notre site internet ça c'est
très important il faut le mesurer
et puis le deuxième point qui est
intéressant c'est que ça permet de
mesurer aussi la façon de savoir si nous
remplissons notre mission de recréer du
lien entre le politique et le citoyen
entre le sénat et les citoyens de faire
connaître le sénat et nos publics nous
disent oui mais je souhaite que nous
progressions encore et nous pouvons ce
sera discuté peut-être dans le cadre du
prochain contrat d un objet d'objectifs
et de moyens rendre cet indicateur plus
fréquents l'élément qui me paraît
important c'est que dans cet indicateur
de satisfaction nous mettions puisque
j'ai parlé du public sénat à la demande
et d'une nouvelle étape de notre
développement numérique nous nous
mettions bien au centre du
questionnement la question de savoir si
désormais nos publics et ça va être le
défi des années à venir nous perçoivent
surtout pas seulement comme une chaîne
de télévision mais bien comme ce média
global dans lequel ils peuvent entrer
par différentes portes le site internet
par l'actualité et toutes les
plateformes où ils peuvent disposer des
contenus de public sénat
des documentaires aux séances
d'auditions en passant par nos magazines
donc oui bien entendu tous les trois ans
actuellement mais nous pouvons le faire
plus fréquemment une mesure de la
satisfaction c'est la bonne approche
pour mesurer cette puissance de public
sénat
merci monsieur kessler alors comme vous
pouvez le constater monsieur kessler il
vous reste un peu plus de dix minutes si
vous voulez approfondir certains aspects
à l'eau
dion de votre conclusion puisque le
temps qui vous est imparti est de 40
minutes au total
bien je pensais pas qu'on avait été si
rapide
voilà alors écoutez je vais conclure en
vous disant ma passion pour cette
mission voilà parce que public sénat
c'est une entreprise à taille humaine
qui est agile qui est en mouvement
créative et où surtout chacun a le
sentiment et c'est tellement précieux
aujourd'hui que ce qu'il fait a du sens
et c'est comme cela
à cette échelle avec ses valeurs avec ce
mode de management fondé sur l' écoute
la collaboration que notre média doit
être appréhendée par celui qui le dirige
pas comme n'importe quel média public
sénat c'est au fond une combinaison une
alchimie qu'il faut non seulement
maîtriser
j'ai l'expérience mais avec laquelle il
faut entretenir un lien affectif et moi
cette chaîne ce média multiples je les
ai vus grandir
je le connais je le vis média ouvert à
tous les publics
et je crois que nous l'avons beaucoup
évoqué mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs dans dans les minutes qui ont
précédé
il doit l'être aussi dans sa vie interne
en favorisant le parcours et la
progression professionnelle de chacune
et chacun dans la parité et la diversité
humaine sociale territoriale et en
permettant l'accès à nos métiers à des
jeunes de tous nos territoires qui n'ont
pas forcément les réseaux pour y entrer
c'est aussi notre responsabilité et
notre mission et notre mission
j'ai des propositions pour cet
engagement dans mon projet notamment au
travers de conventions nous pourrions
passer avec des rectorats dans des zones
prioritaires des zones urbaines mais
aussi des zones rurales et aussi
d'ailleurs des outre-mer si la distance
permet de les faire un moment donné
découvrir par des stages ou pour ceux
qui cherchent un emploi par des
formations professionnelles nos nos
métiers voilà donc ça ça me paraît
extrêmement important je suis un
dirigeant bien sûr exigeant pour lui
même et pour les autres un entraîneur
qui pousse chacun et chacune à toujours
aller de l'avant et qui fait aussi
preuve d'écoutés de bienveillance de
proximité parce qu'une équipe il faut
lui montrer l'objectif mais aussi être
sur le terrain avec elle l'accompagné et
puis dans public sénat il ya le sénat le
sénat votre sénat j'ai envie de dire
notre sénat à public sénat j'y tiens
rien ne se fait sans un dialogue
constant qui nous nourrit avec chacune
et chacun d'entre vous et le sénat
c'est mon port d'attache parce que j'ai
toujours considéré et cela dès mes
débuts dans le journalisme à la gazette
des communes qu'il incarne avec vous
toutes et tous à la fois
l'ancrage dans nos territoires sans
lequel on manque toute compréhension de
la politique et l'attachement au delà
même des sensibilités partisanes et si
ce à quoi je crois aux grands principes
républicains qui doivent nous réunir sur
un plan plus personnel je suis aussi
passionné par l'idée de transmission et
c'est le rôle de notre média que de
transmettre une information fiable qui
soit utile à la formation du citoyen et
qui conforte notre démocratie et je vous
le dis ici si votre décision me le
permet je lancerai à la rentrée sur nos
antennes un grand magazine de débat et
de réflexion sur les libertés
je mentionne cette proposition à ce
moment parce que je voudrais en faire un
marqueur très fort ici au sénat qui est
précisément la vigie de nos libertés
publiques
car je crois qu'au fond tous les grands
enjeux que rencontre aujourd'hui notre
société y compris bien sûr avec cette
crise sanitaire peuvent être regardés
sous le prisme de la liberté vous le
voyez tout ce combat j'y crois c'est ce
qui m'anime
et c'est pourquoi je suis devant vous
cet après midi public sénat pour moi
c'est d'abord
un choix de coeur et si je brigue un
nouveau mandat
c est avec modestie parce que je suis
convaincu que par ces temps orageux je
suis celui qui peut le mieux à lier la
stabilité dont on a besoin pour piloter
ce média et l'innovation indispensable
pour qu'ils s'adaptent aux défis
nouveaux et qu il se réinvente
encore une fois dans cette crise aux
dimensions multiples je pense avoir la
meilleure connaissance de public sénat
du sénat et de vous sénatrices et
sénateurs pour faire face aux enjeux qui
sont devant nous nous sommes à un
tournant à la fois notre vie politique
et de l'évolution de nos métiers de
l'information face aux autres
le drapeau public sénat doit continuer
de se hisser plus haut toujours plus
haut et vous pouvez être certain si vous
m'accordez votre confiance je m'y engage
que j'accomplirai ma mission jusqu'au
bout pleinement sans regarder ailleurs
je serai dans l'action immédiatement
notamment pour faire vivre cette
démocratie territoriale lors des
prochaines élections départementales et
régionales
ma passion est non seulement intacte
mais redoublé par ce qui nous attend je
suis tourné vers l'avenir
je préfère toujours agir en dix ans ce
sera mieux demain que c'était mieux
avant et avec vous c'est ce message
cette énergie cette volonté que je veux
communiquer aux équipes et à tous nos
publics
vous pouvez compter sur moi merci
monsieur kessler pour cette conclusion
sauf qu'à à ce que certains de mes
collègues et
un mot complémentaire à dire mais je
pense que nous allons pouvoir conclure
effectivement cette audition en vous
remerciant est donc cette audition étant
terminée moi je vous propose de marquer
une pause de cinq minutes pour permettre
aux candidats suivants devenir monsieur
kessler
merci beaucoup mon courage
[Musique]